[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour mais c'est mon jean
pierre descombes qui est exceptionnel
c'est le plus fort voilà je vais pas
faire un petit test déjà je pense qu'on
va essayer de faire un petit test tout
de suite avec reem kherici imca ici
c'est parti tu vas être face à jean
pierre descombes alors il va se mettre
très près cela est collé serré
il a une technique c'est une minute tu
ne dois pas dire ni oui ni non pendant
une minute
jean perret est ce que tu es prêt -
jean-pierre sueur sur son éventuelle
réponse rapide
tu l'as attaque il faut répondre tout de
suite tombé d'accord ok ok ça marche au
départ top on démarre démarre tôt c'est
parti un jeune parisien actuellement des
temps en temps et si ça vous plaît paris
s'est pollué
si le trait tout beaucoup pas tout dit
oui non j'ai dit attention tu es prêt
l'attention et minutes mais n'est tombé
un type de joueur
dans ce cas un match de rugby sur le
terrain quand c'est bien bien bien joué
jusqu'à présent ça ma tête et 2003
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention accrue c'est parti bonsoir
bon ça s'en vient comment ça va bien mal
concentré on sentirait l'entente il
change de position je peux être plus
près comme ça ça sert gêne pas vraiment
vu ou entendu tout cela soit lui tous
les soirs
le mercredi c'est votre histoire c'est
que le bétonneur que le mercredi 6
diffusé à quelle heure je ne sais pas du
sport un petit peu ça m'arrive de ce
faux pas de la gym vous avez suivi de
jeux de 20 heures
j'ai le coeur qui bat tu as tenu 7e soit
c'est un ghetto nul plus voilà dans les
yeux à tant d abord obama allait bâtir
avec franck ca va faire ça va alors vous
êtes auteur metteur en scène réalisateur
c'est ça tu vas bien falloir y est pas
encore mais sur une piste franck sur
quoi me pistent pas de piste
pis en pis bon pas de moi un petit peu
de vous qui faisait noir de la promo en
ce moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec hakim et hop c'est bonjour bonjour
n'est pas ça va ça va sur un certain
vela l'enlever si vous voulez je sais
c'est une discussion un peu le truc
c'est ce que j'aime le plus vous avez
apprécié elle tout à fait des enfants
jamais pense pas encore c'est alors
seulement vous j'ai arrêté départ à la
toque à l'époque ça fait des années
seydoux et grammaire orthographe je
préfère les maths ah bon je me suis fait
piquer par une araignée et j'ai eu une
grossesse sur la main qu est ce qu il
faut dire chef la réponse ne connais pas
la réponse et une grosse heure c'est une
grosse heure à paris l'agresseur donc
c'est parmalat aviez joué là je suis
très très chaud et tu sais qu'il ya une
autre engin claude defrance et j'avoue
être une patate de la dentition la
dentition magnifique ça fait plaisir ça
que je dis quelquefois mais bon tant
partition
[Applaudissements]
bah ouais
[Musique]
petit rappel la tension n'en la parole à
marseillais oui extrait du big c paris
bonjour bonjour va tâter à marseille
j'étais à marseille merci vous est
magnifique tu vois pas ce que la plage
actuellement à y fait trop froid sans
ils vont peut-être même si une fille
j'ai une fille et trois garçons pas de
garçons mais j'habite paris également
j'habite paris également très bien il
avait juste que je suis d'accord je
répète pas j'aimerais bien sûr je suis
sûr bon tu fais du sport tas s'est parlé
je fais beaucoup de temps disent jamais
davantage sur les gens j'ai un très
mauvais souvenir j'ai eu un accident
[Rires]
aso doit dire ni oui ni non michaud
capello est à dire et c'est une variante
et bien c'est vrai respire bien un coup
et oui bonjour toujours content de te
voir ça va ça va être serré le jeu de
mata je connais pas non plus tu le fais
avec ta voix ou alors je le fais avec la
voix de charles ix à cepagatti champion
des comptes entre parties top c'est
votre ordi mines on est bien d'accord
cette vingtaine renault qui aimerait
bien retourner à river qui s'est passé
mais par des non stop the party bonsoir
comment vas-tu mon chéri je suis ton
tantôt revendre nord moi je suis très
heureuse de te vois tu sais qu'avec le
loup rentrer gardait tout le temps à la
démission du don dans le coeur oui
[Musique]
attention soit bonsoir de temps ça fait
très très plaisir on était le titre de
la chanson que vous achèterez 14,5
besoin de toi c'est toi alors besoin de
toi c'est une chanson d'amour un ado
corps et comme à taillis j'ai dit oui
sylvie sylvie vartan palestiniens bien
que c'est parti mais bon ce soir bonsoir
jean pierre tu te souviens un peu la
main en exergue quelques chansons
c'était ma chanson ferait la première
que faire un énorme succès et de 47
chansons carlo et ça tu te souviens
c'était aussi télégramme tu peux
beaucoup confiance et vous répndre
prendra-t-on coup vous avez des paroles
à l'époque c'était
je lui ai dit tu peux avoir mais lui il
faut qu'un jour du départ ça va très
bien je trouve très en forme ce soir
très en forme merci c'est gentil mais je
sais écouter le début de ces secteurs
c'est que des blagues mais tu dis fitch
a bien les blagues
j'adore les blagues de plus il a
maintenant le petit us et kaka il a 59
ans fait caca tout ça pour lui
bon ça va très bien j'ai trop peur des
jeux de 20 heures
c'est oublier c'est que tu t'es fan de
maître capello c'était mon ami je sais
que tu veux l'équipe était sentir à
quinze jours de travail de ça je lui ai
demandé oui
[Musique]
pour faire
jean pierre je pense qu'il faut que tu
leur face à face à face avec hakim tueur
face à face à face avec hakim à leur
dernier face à face à lille bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir ça fait bizarre de vous
revoir ça fait extrêmement plaisir de
vos droits vous inviter par ibm où je
crois tout à fait vous pouvez pas
travailler ce soir je peux pas ta moto
je suis en moto au général à bozouls à
elle est juste devant saphir tout à fait
vous allez au théâtre demain ils se
croient demain quelle qu'elle soit je
sais pas encore parce que c'est un titre
encore attendre un petit peu ce que je
sais moi c'est seulement là c'est
excellent at il dit pas du tout on fait
vraiment peur c'est vous qui me fait
peur les jeux de voiture tu regardais
comment les shows de voiture tu
regardais je pas du tout sa fin
d'émission qui te dit quelque chose je
ce maître capello maître capello partie
oui pas du tout s'ils échouent bienvenue
sont pas du tout tu te trouves pas
toujours d'accord
sic la torture c'est vrai que j'ai une
belle aventure okacha vie plusieurs fois
à plusieurs reprises parce qu'en même
temps la dea d'histoire
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez on veut dire au régime
on va recaler apparemment il aurait dit
à plusieurs reprises way sinon
maintenant alors on va voir pour avoir
en régie par on à la barre regardez on
va voir là bas quelques temps tu sais
c'est vrai que j'ai une belle aventure
quand j'ai dit plusieurs fois plusieurs
reprises dès qu'il ya un petit oui c'est
gagné pour hakim jamie lynn
s'ils jouent à remercier jean pierre
davant à taïg khris est clair